un retour dans les kiosques qui fera
plaisir à tous les amoureux de la bande
dessinée pilote le journal mythique qui
a vu naître astérix blueberry ou la
rubrique à brac pilote renaît pour un
numéro unique marie-hélène bono
jean-louis me la reconstitution d'equipe
10 août les anciens du pilote toujours
vers une cinquantaine d'auteurs seul du
début
les petits nouveaux ou mélangé leurs
pinces l'esprit pilote flotte toujours
la semaine dernière comme autant de
goscinny où l'on s'amuse et à réfléchir
les conférences de rédaction c'était
pareil jetez aussi merdique par bungie
ce journal est ce milieu mais non parce
qu'il ya pa t shirt est tout seul et
maintenant on est trois filles donc
formidable
quelles avancées et quelles avancées
avec les jeunes de la bd riad sattouf ou
joann sfar christophe blain ne sont pas
peu fiers de ressusciter le mythe
pourvu que ça dure
content d'être dans le bateau et espère
qu'il va papoul et puis c'est tout
premier numéro trois cent mille
exemplaires tous vendus d'hocine issus
des réseaux et charlie et venait de
créer l'hebdomadaire qui allait
révolutionner la bande dessinée jusqu'en
1989 pilote a marqué des générations de
lecteurs le journal renaît de ses
cendres des nouvelles des reprises des
parodies sur 130 pages un événement
pareil ça se fait en famille toutes
générations confondues est une famille
de gai luron bien sûr
les bonnes choses qui disparaissent sont
pas obligatoirement morte d'explosifs
je pense que c'est dommage que pas un
bon journal de bd si ces pilotes c'est
mieux toujours aussi indisciplinés la
bande de pilotes pas du tout nostalgique
plutôt prête à rempiler